لم نسمع
بنوتام ما قبل لحظه الفوضى هذه في الواقع
ما حدث يوم الاربعاء الماضي وان كان لم
يستمر لاكثر من ساعه ونصف الساعه يعدوا
حدثا تاريخيا في الولايات المتحده في هذا
الوقت القصير ليس في عالم الملاحه الجويه
اكثر من 1300 رحله والغيا وعشره الاف اخرى
اجلت اقل الاضرار في الحقيقه وهي لا تذكر
مقابل سيناريو اقلاع وهبوط الطائرات دون
نظام كانت لتكون هذه الطائرات عمياء ولذلك
قرار تعليق حركه الملاحه كان صائبا
والكلام هنا ليكيت تتجدد وزير النقل
الامريكيه الذي يواجه مازق حاليا وسنعود
اليه بعد قليل
النظام ينبه الطيارين والمطارات لمشكلات
السلامه يعنى بالجليد على المدارس وحتى
باسراب الطيور في اجواء الهبوط لا على
الطائرات ولما خذ كثيرا في تقنيات النظام
الذي انشا قبل اكثر من نصف قرن وتطور من
نسخته الورقيه الى هذا الشكل فا الاهم هو
انه يتحكم في الملاحه الامريكيه والعالميه
بالتاليه
25,000 رحله جويه تحمل مليونين و300 الف
مسافر من والى ما يقرب من 80 دوله
و66.000 طن من البضائع من والى اكثر من
200 وعشرين دوله هذا النظام الضابط لكل
هذه الحركات لما يحدث منذ عام 2015 اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه هي المسؤوله ربما غير
ان الكونغرس وافي في وجهه النظر المعاكسه
لم يدعم الاداره باموال تكفي للقيام
ببطئها العديده بشكل صحيح خبراء يرون ان
ميسانيه الاداره التي بلغت 18 مليون ونصف
مليون دولار في عام 20 20 هي اقل من تلك
المخصصه في 2004 مع احتساب التضخم لا تسمح
بتغيير وتحديث انظمه الطيران الامريكي حتى
انها السبب وراء التدخل تاخر عفوا نظام
النكس جان الذي اطلقه الكونغرس قبل عقدين
لاصلاح شامل لنظام الطيران الوطني في
ميزانيه مليار دولار سنويا هذا النظام
تاخر عن موعده كثيرا رغم انها كانت
تسعون دقيقه فقط لكن توقف الكامل لقطاع
الطيران عاد للذاكره هجمات الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر عام 2001 ما حدث هو الاول من نوعه
منذ ذلك الوقت هذه الدقائق التسعين جعلت
وزير النقل الامريكي في بوتوجينج في مرمى
نيران لم يصل منها اصلا منذ توليه المنصب
قبل عامين
عام 2021 ازمه بسلسله التوريد العالميه
المرتبطه بجائحه كورونا والتي ادت
لاضطرابات هائله في الموانئ الامريكيه في
يوليو الغيت شركات الغد شركات الطيران
الاف الرحلات وطالبه الديمقراطيون انفسهم
باصلاح في اوائل ديسمبر العام الماضي
الطره الكونجرس للتدخل لتجنب اضراب لقطاع
الشحن بالسكك الحديديه بسبب الاجور اما في
نهايه ديسمبر فالغت سوف
الرحلات الجويه بعد عاصفه ضربت اجزاء
كثيره من البلاد ثم اتت ازمه الاربعاء
الديمقراطيه النيران التي يواجهها جمهوريه
الجمهوريون وبسبب كل هذه الازمات اتهموه
بانه غير مؤهل لمنصبه وعلى راسهم تتروس
السنه الثالثه الجمهوري
في اللجنه التي تشرف اصلا على وزاره النقل
وامام هذا الهجوم الجمهوري فالدفاع طبعا
ديمقراطي ومن راس الهرم الرئيس
فيسبوك فيسبوك